[Music]
the gleaming towers of canary Warf
London's banking Mecca headquarters of
HSBC Barkley and
City developed in 1988 it's privately
owned by an international Consortium
Songbird Estates but for how
long the Qatari investment Authority
which is government run and a US
commercial property firm have offered a
takeover bid $3.5 billion it would have
been one of the biggest property deals
in the UK for years but it was slapped
down Songbird chairman David Pritchard
said the proposal undervalues Songbird
and doesn't reflect the inherent value
of the business and its underlying
assets so are they Holding Out for a
better
offer London's commercial rents are
rising and Qatar wants to add yet
another landmark to its string of trophy
assets if its bid is successful the tiny
energy-rich state would own buildings
that make up some of the most famous
parts of London's
Skyline hars the shopping institution
was bought in 2008 for $2.4 billion that
was the starting gun the qataris have
gone on to own 95% of The Shard snapping
that up during the financial crisis add
to that the Chelsea barracks and the
Olympic Village and recently hsbc's 44
story Global headquarters that
reportedly cost just over 1.7
billion the qataris are already the
biggest single shareholders of caner
Warf and with the area expected to
benefit from new rail links and Rising
property demand the other owners might
just be holding out for a bit more Angus
Bennett
Bloomberg